asking oneself and others what the
perfect version of something is the
ideal version might sound like a strange
idea what is the perfect marriage or
career or system of government or school
it can feel immature and naive to bother
much with such questions that just
daydreams after all who cares about
ideal versions we might as well deal
with what we've got but the great
ancient Greek philosopher Plato
strenuously disagrees with this
throughout his work he argues that
focusing on the ideal version of
something is one of the most useful
kinds of thought exercises we can
generate it's by knowing what we think
something should be like that we can
more clearly start to define what might
be wrong and focus on what we need to do
to make the world slightly better when
he was talking about ideals Plato used a
slightly strange but ultimately rather
useful word the forms so he asked not
what is the ideal friendship or the
ideal kind of parental love he asked
what is the form of friendship or the
form of parental love it does sound
strange but what he had in mind was
something very practical when a Greek
stonemason was carving an ornament they
wouldn't just make it up themselves
they'd make use of a wooden template or
form to check if they were getting it
right the form itself was made by the
master but if the Mason possessed the
form they could more reliably do perfect
work this is Plato's basic picture of
what an ideal is it's the guide you need
that shows you how to do something well
yourself if you've got possession of the
form you can be guided towards a true
goal a form as Plato sees it is a
blueprint a set of instructions for
making a very good version of something
that's why we all need a well thought
through
set of forms to guide us in life and
unsurprisingly it is philosophy that can
guide us to these forms so for example
the form of friendship is a mental model
of what a really good friendship
actually involves and if you grasp this
model if this idea is active in your
mind you will know how to be a good
friend
similarly having a form of Education in
mind is going to be very useful for the
teacher
it'll stop her being buffeted by events
and day-to-day pressures she'll be able
to keep in mind we're ideally she should
be going we've typically thought of
ideals as fantasy projections that
blithely ignore most of what life is
actually like we think of them as the
opposite of being realistic but Plato
seasoned ideal as the result of a deep
understanding and careful engagement
with reality someone setting up an
airport would need in the Platonic
scheme to have in mind the ideal air
traffic control system something
optimally effective efficient and safe
this is the person who would in Plato's
terms have grasped the form of air
traffic control we all need to have as
many forms in mind as we possibly can
Plato is breaking the habitual
assumption that searching for the ideal
is at odds with getting things done in
the rough-and-tumble of the real world
and he's pushing us to be more exacting
about where we are trying to head to if
an ideal seems utterly distant and
hopeless maybe the problem isn't that
it's too idealistic but in a strange but
important way actually not idealistic
enough that is we've not quite yet
discovered the form we shouldn't abandon
our ideals we should get more ambitious
about them and Plato's philosophy is on
hand to help us
you